keat no more in case you missed it kim
kardashian and pete davidson are going
their separate ways and now et's got
inside details about the split
who are you texting ken does his name
rhyme with feet
a relationship in the phone was a major
factor here a source blaming the breakup
on kim and pete's busy schedules for the
former snl star this means his stand-up
career as well as a jam-packed schedule
of movie making it's zucchini bread
yum he's currently in australia for a
project and well apparently distance
didn't make the heart grow fonder quote
pete being away for so long was hard for
them our source says in short the spark
between kim and pete faded and she
didn't feel ready for something serious
with him
[Applause]
[Music]
kim and pete were together for a total
of nine months the pair's romance kicked
off with a kiss last fall when kim
hosted saturday night live now are you
gonna kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
the romance played out across social
media as well as some quick mentions on
the kardashians pete is has got to be
literally the best human being i've ever
met like the best heart people always
say like oh he's so funny and it's like
has to do with how funny he is that's
like
fourth on my list of why i like him
following the split we can at least
expect these two to be friendly exes
et's source notes kim still adores pete
and will always be friends with him he's
just super genuine yeah and it's just
really fun to just
hang out and do nothing and
watch tv and just do nothing
that's my favorite thing she still
thinks he's the nicest and sweetest guy
in the world and there's no drama or
anything weird between them now as fans
know kim's love life was at a crossroads
when this romance began i do recognize
the impact that my relationship has had
on my family and i've never had the
opportunity to just say i'm sorry guys
the reality star was and still is in the
middle of divorcing rapper kanye west
who infamously dropped a diss track
about his ex's new relationship
god sent me from that crash
just so i could beat pete davis's ass
our source points out kim thought pete
was good for her at the time because she
felt pete was the opposite of kanye but
what kim thought was going to be a fun
fling turned into something more
and e.t source explains quote kim wasn't
feeling like she was willing to settle
down with him just yet and we know
pete's looking to start his own family
sooner rather than later my favorite
thing ever which i've yet to achieve is
i want to have a kid
that's like my dream wow that's kind of
what i'm just preparing for now is
trying to be like as good as a dude and
develop and get better so when that
happens it's just easier
okay but what about the kardashians of
it all season two premieres this fall
and is expected to show more of their
time as a couple babe yeah do you want
to shower with me really quick
i love that he's
kind and really really thoughtful he's
the most thoughtful person
but we'll likely have to wait for season
three to see what camera's captured when
it comes to this split as for the future
of kim's love life her plans are pretty
straightforward with our source
explaining she's ready to be single and
date again
[Music]